yes
yes hello hello hello welcome back to
roofing with griffin live
here we are live this is live
[ __ ] i see you in the chat the
chat has been going hard for like an
hour which i don't even understand
[Laughter]
uh
i mean has it started it should have
started
all right well here we are we're here i
think it started i think it's live now
so welcome
welcome to uh we're with griffin live
the chat has been going at it for like
an hour
uh these [ __ ] are crazy but
before we start you know how we usually
start because you know i'm ready
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen
welcome back
to a live version of your
favorite podcast
[Music]
[Music]
we got
[Music]
wow
[Music]
yeah
yeah
yeah that's that dope-ass dopa pod theme
song i love it every time we play it so
you see i got y'all in there i mentioned
some people in the chat so that's there
um
welcome guys um i don't even know what
to say you know but before you know wha
before we start let me just uh do some
some some business you know what i mean
uh just i want you guys to
remember that i
also also game
i play call of duty all the time i play
modern warfare all the time uh and you
can find that you know right there on
twitch and youtube i love doing that's
fun and i've been a lot of times i've
been playing with the fans my most
recent
uh stream we uh actually won we actually
won we got a win we finished fifth place
second place and then we got a victory
this dude was like it was dope in the
end so make sure you guys check that out
eric griffin gaming
and just do just to do some other
business real quick let's do that
you know make sure you go to my twitter
eric griffin
i'm eric griffin on twitter and i just
did this great thing with uh all things
comedy and it's on my twitter right now
it's this thing called the minorities
report i'm gonna actually play a little
clip of it right now from my twitter
i think you guys can see why i don't
like that's why i don't like medical
shows on tv because there's not one
filipino nurse on grey's anatomy it's
true you know what i mean not one i want
to see a medical show with all filipinos
yeah because that's what it is and it
comes on at eight o'clock
how many times did i watch your ers your
grey's anatomies your all that stuff and
i'm like half of my iranian friends are
doctors any hospital you go to in los
angeles you got a bunch of iranians
bunch of indians all that finally after
like 20 years they got one indian doctor
on grey's anatomy or something
but anyways so there's that you know
what i mean
um that's uh uh that make sure you also
check me out on instagram
you know i got my gram going on too
uh a lot of fun stuff on there and look
at this look of mine what do you guys
think of this right now this new look
and now i feel like i can't go back i
either have to go shaving with a little
grizzle or i have to do this now it's
crazy everybody's been getting on my
case man you done your mustache have you
been doing your mustache and my whole
[ __ ] is like who cares
sometimes you you have to do i did this
movie this movie called val
um and it was um
it was um what do you call it
i had to she wanted it black so she
wanted to because of the character so
sometimes i'm gonna have to dye my hair
or whatever it is you know if you guys
see will smith like will smith is all
gray but like when he's in a movie and
he's playing a certain character
sometimes he's he dyes everything so he
looks a little younger i mean it is what
it is i'm into business i mean am i vain
about it sometimes but then i look at
myself and i go who cares
because it looks ridiculous even when i
look back on my mustache right now you
know i look back on the mustache and i
just i don't know
i don't know if i like it or not
you know now i look at the mustache and
it looks like it looks like how when i
was a kid how i used to look at people
in the 70s when they had like
it looks like from a fargone era
you know what i mean
so i don't know it's just weird so i i
i'm looking at it and i'm like all right
do i want to keep this look right now so
we'll see so make sure you check me out
on there and then i also had you know
i have a patreon boo yeah i'm still
working on it you know i don't have a
lot of members but if you want to join
the patreon this is patreon.com eric
griffin so make sure you check that out
and then like as you know you guys are
here you know my last episode because
this is a bonus episode i'm doing right
now this week just a bonus live friday
episode as bonus but the last episode of
riffing with griffin was with adam
devine
so that was pretty good i love that dude
and you know here's a little bit of that
one
i love that guy though because he put me
in this movie he put me in uh
in uh murder mystery
so it's like
from the workaholics family you know
we're we're still oh yeah i know that
was cool seeing you in that yeah there
was a lot there's a lot of workaholics
people the tree from workaholics you
know i've been doing
i've been on many shows and sets where
somebody comes up to me and goes hey i
was a writer on workaholics season two
and i'm like oh
i never yeah so anyways that was uh that
episode of uh
of workaholics
i mean of riffing with griffin
with the one of the main workaholics and
y'all i want to thank uh the super chats
are you getting a super chat in i really
appreciate that
donzi mayez i don't know if i'm saying
it right
yes which is super chat
so thank you for that
so anyways i'm here i wanted to do some
q a with you guys you know the chat's
going kind of fast so i'll try to get to
that but just i wanted to just talk a
little bit about like what's going on
with me
and just talk to you guys and see how
everybody's doing out there you know i
mean i just want like i had a moment
with my girl because she was
because it happens to me like i get sad
every day
around 9 00 p.m
because that's the time i'm supposed to
be headed to the comedy store i'm
supposed to be headed to the lab factory
doing some shows so around that time my
body's kind of like yo bro what are you
doing why aren't you getting ready why
aren't you getting your mind right what
are you thinking about your set why
aren't you like getting amped up to go
like release energy
so i get sad you know i mean i get
really depressed sometimes and i don't
know what you guys are out there getting
depressed about but i'm sure that you
know whatever is like you're used to
doing that you're not doing and you know
you feel depressed and then we have to
have our work like people that have to
go to work
you know they're feeling like you know
they're freaking green berets now
because they're going to work like i'm
risking my life to go do this you know
that's how the the feeling is in the air
so like my girl even got sad the other
day you know my girl was emotional so
she started to get upset because she was
like i missed restaurants and then that
made me go oh yeah it's like you know
what i mean
you just miss [ __ ] uh oh we got super
chat interlude
anyway so the um
you know so you just you just get these
feelings you know and you don't want to
feel that way you know what i mean like
you don't want to feel like
like
you're just getting sad for no damn
reason but
you're not getting sad for no damn
reason i just wanna i'm i'm i wanted to
do this right now to reach out to you
guys just to say like yo look
you're gonna be upset sometimes you're
gonna have good days and you're gonna
have bad days
you know
and
when you're having one of those bad days
i suggest some exercise you know what i
mean i suggest some like
um
just something to like take your mind
off [ __ ] okay so you guys can make me
sing every time you do this now so i'm
gonna actually have to play play a song
with it
oh yeah
we got a we got a super chat from
uh
[Music]
73 big big big big big
73 with that
[Music]
you know so
anytime you feeling like
you know weird
it's normal you know what i mean it's
just a normal thing to uh
feel
right it's just crazy
so and then there's people out there
just lonely like who's by himself like
imagine like
i think i'd be going crazy if i was by
myself
you know what i mean
oh my god
we have to do that one for this guy
if you if you become a member
oh yeah oh yeah
that's ryan just became a member
[Music]
[Music]
anyway
like who's lonely out there i had this
tweet i put up about um
side chicks i was just joking around but
i was like man imagine all those side
chicks alone
you just at home but i thought about it
it actually sucks i mean there's a lot
of people who like their girlfriends or
boyfriends or they can't be with them
because of whatever reason or there's
people that are just not in
relationships and they're used to not
being in relationships
you know what i mean like like some
people are just not used to being in
relationships anyway but the fact that
now you don't even have the ability to
like be in a relationship like what
like what is that about like i saw
tiffany haddish went on a
like a a facetime date with common
and i was like what
what is that like is that a thing is
that how we're gonna like meet people
by the way though i feel like that's how
you should meet people anyway like even
if you meet somebody on the app let's
say you meet you swipe right on somebody
on tinder or whatever facebook instagram
you in the dms however you meet people
you know what i mean however you meet
people wait hold up hold that thought
we gotta hold that thought
[Music]
anyways thank you jack hill um
like you should do that anyways my point
to get back to it is like that's my
point you should
for sure
swipe start talking and then be like yo
get me on the phone right now let's talk
on the phone you know what i mean we
gotta talk on the phone we gotta see
each other you should facetime right
away it just makes more sense to me you
know what i mean
[Music]
uh oh guess what
this dude named andrew just said two
dollars
he said that two dollars
two dollars
two dollars
uh
super chat
that's how we rap super chat
all right
anyways um
like you to me you should like get off
of the the distancing of
connection
start moving towards being in front of
somebody so you should like talk to
somebody like go fake you know i'm
telling you right now you face time with
a [ __ ] before you meet them and
it might change your mind like you could
talk to somebody for months be like
flirting and whatever and saying [ __ ]
and sexting and doing all these things
and then when you like you know when you
finally get to them
you talk to them on facetime and you're
like
i don't like this [ __ ] hold up
y'all wait a minute you see this
oh [ __ ]
jeff
jackmackey
[Music]
so i'm about to bust another line
[Music]
[Music]
come cody in 399 just like the other men
here come red man now dollar 99
[ __ ] say wow
y'all don't know about eg skills
rapping for these bills
oh eels
let's get back to the talk and chill oh
wait can't stop here come johnny go with
five dollars in the drop
[Music]
okay
actually jeremiah hit me up today about
the country album all right let's get
back to it okay
uh i could do two things at once so
remember to like i said
so
reach out to people so maybe that's the
answer right now guys is to reach out to
people
and make them um
make them [ __ ]
talk like
meet you and stuff maybe it's a good way
to uh
maybe it's a good way to like meet
people for for the for once
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
oh what's his name named big cam gear
sending money with no fears
[Music]
so i can hit these
[Music]
okay i started something bad here
because y'all gonna keep
cutting me off but
while the steve interview is playing
don't well you can say what you want
i'll come back later and do it
um
anyways you know what let's actually get
to the steve interview right now this
was pre-recorded it's a pre-recorded
steve interview i talked to him about a
week or so ago steve's my my dude
and uh i like him a lot he's really cool
um
oh rick glassman's here
there he is rick glassman sending money
with no fears okay since rick glassman
is here y'all
oh and just rages saying something he
said that
hit that dollar forty percent
[Music]
here we go here we go
[Music]
oh come on
[ __ ] this what have i started dude this
is like i can't even get past this now
oh yeah
here we go
here we go here we go
rather said 10 bucks i don't know what
n.o.k is but thank you
but thank you and we got liz zulander
sending five dollars for defender
like a salamander
eric griffin is a calendar
cause i'm here all the time
so i can bust these rhymes if it may
march in june
i'll see you soon
oh my god here comes somebody else i
don't even see this guy alright here we
[Music]
and we go
just s with two dollars
two dollars
that's all you get for two dollars
all right okay enough all right i'm
gonna send we're gonna play this steve
interview but let me tell you something
about the steve interview um it was like
when i was still having a little bit of
technical difficulties so the there's
some parts of it it got weird and the
ending was totally shot
so but we had this funny moment and i
just ended it there and i'll be back so
for now make sure you guys enjoy
um
enjoy this interview with steve stevie
weeby steve lee my dude and please enjoy
and i'll be back on after and we can
still do some more q a and have some
more fun here we go here's steve um back
at it once again
quarantining with griffin skype edition
and one of my favorite people in the
world
is now joining the show
what's up mr steven
lee
hello yeah buddy stevie weeby
you know what's hilarious is you're
laying down right now the same way bobby
was laying down
i love it like the exact like you guys i
love it this is the best i didn't think
i'd be able to do this laying down and
relaxing on my own bed
how you been doing buddy yeah you know
it's it's difficult you know it's just
for me the hard part is like just being
bored and not and feeling like i'm not
doing enough like just feeling easy i
got some good yeah i got some good news
for you though what's that
i downloaded warzone
oh
yes are you ready to talk about it you
ready to twitch with me that game is so
fun dude i'll tell you my first
experience what was that i flew in
i went until one of these houses and i
walked out and someone shot me and it
was that quick
you got to be you got to have your head
on a swivel you know what i mean you
can't you gotta
it was so not fun i just went
and turned off the xbox
and i'm like all right well the first
time you play i said
but let me tell you something i got my
first solo victory i know the whole
world's heard about it yeah you know i'm
just we know you won
i understand it was the way
everybody told me it was just exciting
it was just exciting can it be exciting
can i be excited can i be excited
yeah you can
you won a solo game and there's 150
people on there right yes out of 150 and
it was great i had to come back see the
thing i like about warzone you hide in
it because i yeah you can hide but hot
is not fun
but you can come back though if you die
you can come back you get like going to
gulag and you get you know what i mean
you get a chance to i don't like that
part of it
let me tell you at first it was super
hard for me to but i figured it out you
get you you explain what the gulag is to
the listeners and oh so so when you die
in this like battle royale game you get
a russian bath house called the gulf you
get one chance to come back
and you have to go one-on-one against
another player and russia yeah
i guess it is a bath house huh never
thought of it like that
you explained it to me a gulag is like a
russian bath house and it's literally
you can throw smoke bombs and yeah
someone on their team could say where
you are
well if you're playing with other people
yeah game's a nightmare is it fun oh
it's super fun you really get used to it
let's let's be real compared to pug g oh
it's way better pubg is it's different
nightmare no it's different it's way
different it's it actually it's it's
more fast paced
it's uh more fun more exciting easier to
shoot easier to use the guns it's it's
it's actually the war zone with
mechanics are very similar i would say
almost to destiny in terms of like where
you're shooting is where you're shooting
you right you know what i mean well the
thing i notice is it's a lot more
believable like because with destiny i
could get 100 hit a hundred times but
with this it's like
i'm dead oh yeah if you're not if you
get hit in the head especially too a
headshot like
done
you're done yeah man yeah that doesn't
seem fun to me
at all
you'll you'll find it i don't like the
[ __ ] that when you're flying down on
your parachute people can kill you
i had anxiety seeing the other people go
where i was going
[Music]
it's fun man i'm telling you you got to
play more
landed in my parachute and craig's like
go go go grab that chest i grabbed it
got a better weapon than i had right and
then i literally tried to run into a
different building and this guy followed
me and just shot me and now and then i
just turned off the xbox i'm like that
was it for you
that's it i just that's not fun yeah i
feel you dude no i i had i have a good
time playing that uh i've gone i've gone
back to destiny i've tried to play
there's just steve what's going on
all right my thing fell there's just too
much uh
there's too much um what do you call it
stuff to do in destiny there's too many
like
places to go and there's nobody there
ever you know what i mean well the moon
that one place on the moon like where
you have to kill the nightmares that's
fine
yeah
there's different rounds i know but like
here's the problem with that
it's supposed to be matchmaking and
there's never anybody there there's like
a plen there's a lot of stuff where you
can go and you're supposed to match make
with people and you never do because
there's so many of them not enough
people are playing that's my have you
played trials of osiris no i'm not even
960. i can't even play
and some guy shotgunning you in the chat
in the [ __ ] um stomach you're just
dead dead you're dead it's like because
you know what they're doing you know the
problem with that is the elite players
figured out that
all they had to do is win three rounds
and just get the tokens and so they're
farming the first yes i heard that so
like the the skill base they weren't
going up
you know to the lighthouse right right
so you would be playing the hardest
people the first three rounds
wow it was hard just to get one win it's
good luck
steve
yeah go ahead can we do one thing can
you like back up from the camera a
little bit
yeah yeah keep your camera where it is
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah this is gonna
be good they just back up from it
because like i had this new overlay and
something's like covering your mouth i
guess that didn't make it any better but
no that's good that's good
you know i'm going to fix the i'll fix
it on this i'll fix it on the screen
um
yeah that's what i hear but you know
they always have those problems with um
they always have those problems with uh
um what do you call it
what trials osiris yeah they always have
these like little these little
situations at first until they
until they figure it out you know what i
mean right right right right right so
until they get it i don't like the new
the story mode and like a crota and air
there's more
i i
i don't dislike it any
destiny's my favorite when you're trying
to
when you're trying to um
it's my favorite when you're trying to
uh rank up because there's so much to do
and you're always like trying to do that
but once you get to the rank then it's
like okay now what then that's when it
just like becomes like this isn't fun
anymore you know what i mean you know
what's not fun is the new um armor 2.0 i
don't have you figured that out i don't
even know how to rank up the armor this
is what i'm oh dude i'm totally with you
with that like i have no idea and then
the um
these modules
yeah i have no idea how that stuff
to works your gear and your weapons
yeah yeah and then you have to grind for
that just to rank up just in future i
know and then you have that you have to
grind and then there's that there's that
other thing too that other like um what
do you call it that uh so you have like
the the there's like three things you
need to get all to the very to get your
level 10 of your gear yeah you know and
i just i don't
i don't want to do that sometimes
i still play it though i like to grind
yeah i i still play too but
i've really been enjoying war zone i've
been i enjoyed that a lot we can't hear
enough of it coming from you
know we know you want do we need to get
you a [ __ ] trophy like i know no it's
just you know why because on the other
call of duty call of duty black ops the
the battle royale of that oh i'm not
even i haven't won that one yet it's way
harder that one's way harder than
warzone i haven't won that one yet
so
did you document that like you filmed
yourself winnie
oh yeah it's online
it was on my instagram what are you
talking about you know i had that [ __ ]
out there you damn right it was
so tell me this tell me this i know how
hard it was so i feel you but tell me
this man we can still talk about video
games but i'm just curious as to how
you're what let me what's happening with
you with during the corona what's your
whole uh
what how are you dealing with all this i
hate it yeah
let's get it so oh you know what i don't
like about it and i try to talk about
this on tiger belly but i didn't want to
get too too into it but right i don't
like the way it's making people's ultra
paranoid
like ultra paranoid i understand we have
to take precautions but dude i've never
have experienced this type of paranoia
and it's just people are there people
are getting really weird and paranoid
right and how so how have you
experienced it well dude the buying and
the hoarding of groceries and paper
towels and toilet paper that's just one
aspect right right right right but it
was like even at the grocery store the
lady there was act like i didn't know
the code for like potatoes and like she
was scared to come to my checkout
counter thing right she was like next
time you you have to figure out what
code it is
and know the code for the potatoes sir i
know
i had to do everything in my power to
just keep cool because i'm like you were
going to regular you go red zone and
ralph
yeah yeah
why should i know that yeah
and just the way just people are acting
crazy i mean
you know the media doesn't help because
all they're pumping out is
you're going to die you're going to get
it you're going to contract it fear fear
fear you're going to die stay at home
don't talk to anyone
keep your distance you know it's just
all like negative [ __ ] you know i don't
like it and then you can't even tell
like who
you can't you don't even know who to
listen to symptomatic like i could have
it show no symptoms and then i could do
like come on man
so it's like the way they package this
thing is
anyone is suspect yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah anyone and everyone is suspect yeah
it's really i don't like that yeah it's
really scary like my girlfriend my
girlfriend's friend because my girl
worked she was she was still working at
a time when it first started to happen
so then like her mom because her mom was
like yeah can you like go
go stay at eric's
you know what i mean so it's like
you know let's make your family like you
know fight with each other it's like oh
yeah you know what i mean
it's it's causing a bunch of family
disputes yeah and you're just there
you're just so you're just at your place
you know
i mean like you got the door at the dorm
room
on the flip side i kind of like it also
why is that
because it's like i got my whole little
man cave
are you saying are you saying because
your girlfriend can't come over your
girlfriend can't come over
what is that your girlfriend can't come
over and fuss at you is that what you're
saying
no that's that's a bad thing i mean i'm
like i miss that i heard
i like the fact that no one could give
me a hard time for waking up or getting
up or i'm getting all my work done i'm
editing i'm doing video
trying to stay active getting all that
done right getting that done but
um
i i vote you know like we're we're we're
like the same like we're i'm naturally a
loner anyway you know like yeah you're
kind of introverted for sure yeah i'm
introverted so it's kind of like that
couldn't get ahold of you
yeah dude this is people that are
shut-ins love this [ __ ] they're like oh
they love you yeah i don't go out anyway
oh yeah yeah
people just stay in they're like
destiny the sun's coming you know how we
used to play yeah man i'm still doing
that yeah people like [ __ ] people fine
i'm playing i get all my um bounties
done yeah you know what i'm saying i'm
like
the only bad thing is just like
the scarcity i feel like dude it's like
good luck finding a toilet uh roll a
toilet paper or are you not are you not
doing you're not doing this
man yeah i know
you can't even find palmolive or i can't
i can't find it i just ordered some
dishwashing stuff yeah i just got it in
the mail today you're so funny you say
you have to do it on amazon yeah you got
to go to like amazon you got to go to
like wherever you can but then
i ordered from amazon and it took two
days
you know because it was like you had to
get these windows now so the windows are
like you know they're so scarce
yeah i mean so it's just it is weird out
there it's weird
i just i hate being in all the time
i well with you it's different because
you make your half your career as being
on stage and traveling yeah
joe's being in texas louisiana colorado
you're doing your thing yeah this is
weird so how are you how are stand-up
comedian this is my question to you
how are you stand-up comedians holding
up during this quarantine it's tough you
know it's tough because you have that
lack of uh that the the release of
creative energy you know what i mean and
that you do four or five times a week
and then on the weekends you're doing it
for an hour at a time on stage six times
yeah just getting all that energy out is
like it's tough
it's tough that that's gone
and
then you're what you do
your title for what you do you need that
live crowd i do i mean like periscope
you're sad like hey everybody no it's
weird they're trying
to stand up in that room you're like
they're trying though dude they're
trying they're trying to set up
they're trying to set up like
like zoom shows because it's like you
can hear everybody laughing at once you
know people are in their house and
they're just i just don't know how
that's gonna work you know maybe i mean
yeah because who knows how long this is
going to last so we have to just do what
we have to do we have to deal with
whatever we have to deal with but you're
well i'm curious what's your guess how
long is this going to go till august or
what
i think it's going to go until i keep
saying this it's going to go till we get
a vaccine
um but
in terms of getting closer to regular
life it's going to be when the testing
is easier it's going to be like you know
the test it could be like you put
something on your tongue and when you
pull it out it says pot like a like a
pregnancy test when when it's that easy
to know and then you know what you need
to do it's like you need to stay home
maybe they'll come up with some
medications to help with the symptoms
and then you just have to you just have
to get past it and then you're okay but
until it's like that it's this is going
to continue because
you know
but i heard by her what have you been
doing with your time
i've been working on my [ __ ] podcast
i've been gaming more i'm doing two
episodes like like when we recorded this
on a thursday tomorrow friday i go live
with my podcast so every so i'm putting
out two episodes a week sometimes three
you know like i put out yes
oh yeah like this i'll i'll call
somebody like this like you like we'll
talk for longer than i'll talk to most
people because some people i'll talk for
like 20 minutes and then so what i do is
i'll go live on fridays and then i'll
then i'll play that recorded call as
part of that episode the live episode on
project even that youtube live like how
you yeah youtube live i just go youtube
live
oh you get donations and stuff on time
yeah i mean it just depends i'm not
asking for that i mean the only thing
i'm asking my fans to do is watch my ads
you know what i mean like like don't
like don't turn the ads off keep the ads
on you know what i mean that's the only
thing that's the only thing i ask just
keep the ads on so we could uh you know
so people can uh see that like like this
guy i usually could have done live if i
wanted to like i could just go live
whenever you know what i mean like oh
look i'm talking to you you can do that
on your phone can't you you can do it on
your phone too yeah yeah yeah you can do
it on your phone but i mean you know i
want the system set up you know what i
mean i just i mean you know
you could do okay so that's the way
you're flipping you're doing youtube
live and then they're doing like through
facetime and everything yeah i mean dude
i can easily come i
just have to come by and like show you
how to get it off don't you have an
elgato did you don't you have an elgato
capture card i got it somewhere i don't
know i remember back when we're gaming
yeah you gotta pull that sucker out
because that's how you just then you can
just use your camera like we're doing
this the tech portion of the show then
you can hook your you can hook your
whatever good camera you have that you
do with your podcast you can use the
lumix the lumix use your lumex to go
live so it's good quality
oh yeah i love that damn good camera
yeah yeah yeah so you could do it like
that man you know yeah and then i've
been like just watching [ __ ] shows
and movies and documentaries man you
know you watch uh tiger king yeah it's
like everybody so people talked about it
ad nauseum at this point but we don't
have to talk about it i want to hear
your thoughts tell me what did you think
of it
they already know what i think of
because i had a whole episode about it
but you tell me i think that
they're all at fault you know just for
the nature of what they did you know i
mean
i felt that for the the tigers man
they're like you know they're they're
meant to roam free and run around yeah
and then there's so much there's so much
drama revolving around all their
different stories and everything and
yeah they all seem pretty terrible
people you know
yeah like cult leaders right they all oh
yeah yeah yeah they all seem like
they're weird religious cult leaders it
was weird yeah
i'm going i'm also going on through the
old black mirrors i'm watching all the
oh have you not you never saw that
before
no i did but i'm like visiting
revisiting it oh sweet sweet yeah it was
funny i started watching glee because my
girlfriend never seen it
oh
first season the glee is really funny it
is the first season is really funny and
then it just went off it turned it
turned into an after school special
after that but the first season
again it's a musical yeah it's just a
musical thing and then you know just it
just turned into like
don't worry about you wouldn't like it
but it just
but then i've been watching like my
girls got me watching all these really
weird shows like there's this netflix
show about cleaning up with this like
asian lady you know
it's so [ __ ] bizarre can i talk about
it oh please that's yeah i just saw an
episode right now i'm doing great
but we i'm gonna do it on sunday it's so
you should you know what we should both
record ourselves doing it and then we
put it on an episode of stevie wiebe and
griffin
you're doing the marine condo method yes
yes you know you put everything on your
bed you know what i mean all your
clothes no no the main thing you have to
touch every item oh i know i know i know
you need to go like this
like if i want to throw this away thank
you you know
you have to you have to what are you
laughing at man she knows what she's
talking about man don't go talking down
you know what she actually you know what
you you and her could be brother and
sister like if you had a wig on you
would look just like her
don't go over there
i was having a good time up until to
this point my friend
please don't do this you look like a
cute asian
you don't woman like that don't do that
but it's a good show so i've been
watching that and there's a lot of weird
shows like that on netflix well if the
thing about it can i talk more about it
please do go ahead steve she breaks it
down you're not you're supposed to break
it down in categories yeah okay
so the first category
is clothing yeah and this has to do with
shoes sweaters hats
everything socks
and that's what i did i touched every
item
and um
yeah man it took me a while but i did it
you know
like i just kept the things that like
brought joy to me you know what i mean
oh wow yeah that's the one yeah that's
the thing that she was talking about
things that bring you joy
yeah absolutely and i know exactly what
i know exactly what she meant because
it's like
like i have certain shirts like i like
to wear my captain america shirt that's
my favorite shirt you know it's like
you're not gonna throw that away right
exactly you know but the problem i was
having is like so my girl and i are
talking about it
and then
i
was looking at one of my shirts like oh
yeah this is one and she was like i
don't know about that shirt i'm like you
can't be like that
right right my joy has nothing to do
with yours
exactly that's has nothing to do with
her it's you you know what i mean so
it's like you know it's so yeah it's
first clothing and then it's books and
then it's papers and bills and they just
break it down in categories yeah then it
was like in different rooms too like
different rooms like miscellaneous
things and like the garage and your
bedroom photos that's a whole lot yeah
oh you know what i'm saying yes it's an
interesting show what's it called i
believe it's called like tidying up or
something i forgot what it was yeah i
have the book you know what's crazy
is
the way i have my phone set up
it's on top of the murray condo book
just just don't don't mess with it
because we got it called life-changing
magic of tidying up oh i'd like to yeah
and that's the name of the show on that
way let me see what the name of the show
is on well i'm talking about the book i
don't know about the show i'm talking
about the book it's amazing but that's
just one of the shows i've been watching
this is the main theme that i got too i
just read i just read this the other
night
it's kind of like the when you do each
category if you decide to do like today
i'm going to do my books it's gotta be
like it's gonna take time you know yeah
yeah yeah yeah and another thing is
steve in or out with the gum is it gonna
is it gonna be in your mouth or out of
your mouth like you don't understand
you're so closed up on the screen right
now that gum is flowing
looks like that other people have
complained about it it's nicotine okay i
got it you need it
i need it yeah what i'm going to start
with my desk right right because my desk
is a pigsty
and so the problem with that is
let's say it's not about like
conquering one thing because let's say
i like collect lotion bottles or
whatever pens
even it's like yeah that's why she
breaks it down in categories you know
what i'm saying yeah
so yeah so i'm i'm just learning about
it like i'm gonna read more tonight like
i'm like taking this seriously like it's
not like a joke to me yeah but then we
also have time it's like there's
something else going on so it's like
yeah it's it's good to feel like i felt
bad though because
craig got me um
a hat uh you were saying i should have
sold it but i'm like dude it's not it's
not like even a personal thing you know
this reminds me of that book you threw
away that
what is it
jordan peele or jordan whatever's
key
that was like a christian christian book
yeah oh yeah that sort of kind right i
just had to do it you know what'd you do
with it
how did i do it you threw a
one-of-a-kind jacket away
i threw a lot of stuff like a lot of
monchi like from the band right like the
band stuff like
a lot of like
hats and shirt like stuff that like is
like one of a kind this is the thing at
one point in my life
i wore that every day
but now like today is a different day
you know yeah yeah so like things change
you know yeah i've been doing the same
kind of thing i look at my closet and
everything you look in your closet and
you grab a shirt and you go i haven't
worn this [ __ ] shirt in
in years what am i doing with this shirt
your brain occasionally yeah for like a
wedding or a birthday but that day never
comes it never comes and it just fills
your closet with nonsense yeah yeah and
i love that i love the folding thing too
thing man and i love the folding too
that she you know what i mean how you
fold your clothes and all that [ __ ]
that's great and having little boxes to
put things in in your drawers and
organizing stuff so that's a good one
you're doing it for real we need to move
out some of your [ __ ] and i'm like yeah
i'm looking at all my stuff and i'm like
yeah i do have a lot of [ __ ] that i just
don't need even in my office right here
with all my podcast stuff i i look
around and i'm like i don't need that i
don't need this i don't need that i need
to move this you know so it's just one
of those things that you just like you
know you just got to do but that is a
very fascinating show how bizarre how
ironic that is right yeah that's so
crazy because i'm like that's like i'm
like implementing that right as we speak
like like last night dude you didn't
even know what i did i went through all
my papers like every single piece of
paper
in my desk like i'm talking about even
tax forms and bills it's just everything
i went through each one and i'm like in
for the hundredth time and i just like
with me with movies like
unless
oh i saw 1917 finally oh you did what'd
you think i liked it dude that was a
kick-ass movie
yeah like it impressed me on different
levels but just the fact that they used
almost like just like one shot
or they made you they made you believe
it was one shot you know yeah yeah
that was impossible but it seemed like
like why did it do it
this adventure this guy's during these
two people's journey you know but it was
also just incredible just when you're
watching it because you're just like
where's the camera how did they do that
and like you know yeah
just really
each class like
what you know what's like good for like
one
person might be like a tragedy for you
know like the flooding scene where the
the the storm came and then the but it
was like nothing happened to the rich
people like you know their their
mansions but like with the main
characters you know because they lived
in the ghetto yeah and how it like
flooded out prison
that's got like 250 floors
and on the top floor
like everybody's favorite food in the
whole prison before you go in they ask
you what's your favorite food and no
matter what it is
it's on this platform
and so it goes down to each cell
yeah and it just shows how the people at
the top eat everything and they leave
nothing for the people on the bottom oh
wow you know and it's just like it's
it's such a bizarre movie it's really
bizarre but you know i watched that
that's on netflix it's a tv show or a
movie it's a movie
okay is it an asian movie no but i
believe it's foreign because but you
know what i'll say for netflix which i
really enjoy is like if it's a foreign
film the dubbing the actors they use for
that it's great so you don't really
the only thing that bothers you is that
the mouths are moving different but like
you you feel like it's that person
because back in the day that the the
like they used to dub asian movies back
in the day yeah it was so bad
you know what i was like kung fu yeah
dude like it'd be like i'm gonna get you
for you now it's like no the
motherfucker's not talking like that
he's a real person you know what i mean
right so they used to ruin those movies
so
i will say that the the the voice over
work in the netflix movies they actually
deserve an award some of these
voiceover work because they also do it
for like all the different languages too
because when you go to the the voice
over settings you can change it to
russian german you know you can change
it to so many different things the
original language you know this one is a
like i just started somebody recommended
to me on instagram a movie called
a show called money heist and it's a
yeah it's a show out of spain and again
it's dubbed but it's pretty it's pretty
good i'm enjoying it so far so that's
another one i recommend yeah are you
like are you big on like tv series like
watching like you know um
you know because you know me and me and
craig will work on a music video so
we're doing i know and i saw it the
music video was great i tweeted it out i
don't know if you know that but i put it
on my mind i appreciate it actually did
you like it yeah i did i like i put this
balloons right is that what it's called
what's the name of it it's called
goodbye balloon
yeah
yeah it's about steve's dad and you can
check it out i put it on my i put it on
my youtube uh community thing i put it
on instagram and i tweeted about it so
i appreciate that yeah but so we're
we're we're busy working with that but
then i was gonna go on to say that i've
been i got back into destiny too so now
you're just in a rabbit hole bobby told
me bobby told me yesterday when we we
recorded for his episode
he was like he's playing playstation
because he doesn't want to get wrapped
up but with you and i because you know
we gonna start playing games
i think it's going back to
[Music]
i wish you didn't do that
does that ruin my date
[Laughter]
[Music]
um
so what happened you know what that
disturbed me it bothered me so much i
forgot what i was gonna say you were
telling us about you had to scoop about
bobby in the playstation
it's not playing it's him screaming
because remember when we i know i know
that i know we used to do um
elder scroll the l was that prison of
elders yeah we used to yell at six
o'clock in the morning
but they got a big house there don't
they got a big house now and he's got a
little area to play video games but i
think the main thing it's not him
playing it's him his reaction when it
gets intense him screaming yeah yeah
yeah no no no he's going to be on soon
well he's playing playstation
no he's going to order another xbox he
said and he's going to be on destiny
yeah he says that but then he's like no
no no he he told me the other day he was
going to do it all right we'll see are
you back in or what are we going to do
like the
air key and do something yeah let's get
that old school the original we got to
get the originals back we got to twitch
it we gotta go on twitch and youtube and
do it like that
yeah so maybe maybe you guys out there
see uh steve and i playing warzone
together do some duos
you're gonna have to walk me through
that game i have no idea how to even
float in there
yeah i i i
trust me dude it took me a long time i
just remembered that remember that one
time worst fire team we played pub g
like i didn't even know that friendly
fire was on and i killed you
i don't know if i want to play with you
on this you can't there's no friendly
fire in this one you would leave me in
this chat not even dude that's crazy
take all my grenades craig's the worst
my ammo craig's the worst he's always
just running and he has some excuse it's
like dude be a team fight with me you
know what i mean but yeah you played
with the boys oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's and they just went to quads see
before it was only three players
yesterday was the update and now you now
four people can play on a team now so
that's going to be so i could play you
me coke and craig yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah you got to come in they got good
guns it's fun
so we can play as a team
i don't know if we'll play as a team but
we can play
yeah i know it's just but that's what
makes it fun i mean isn't that the fun
of it
yeah i mean can you snipe in it you can
do it oh yeah you could do all
that landmines yes dude all that stuff
it's fun
smoke bombs good good grenades good guns
it's a fun game dude i'm telling you
it's gonna be fun like i don't know if i
like that's why i don't want to get back
in the um like uh with charles of osiris
on destiny i never had fun
i never have fun playing that game it's
worse
it's worse it's a hundred times worse
i'm not you can't right when you go in
to a game right people are running at
you like a hundred miles per hour i know
so i'm saying there's no room to breathe
you can't even like think
people are jumping around with their
shotguns boom yeah yeah yeah
yeah
i can't with that i can't you know the
meta turned to auto rifles you know
everyone's using hard light and i know
there's like you ever play crucible and
that hard light is just kick
i don't like the ricochet right now
neither they could say right
i know
like you just you just see like bullets
flying all over the screen yeah i don't
like i don't like that i don't like that
either yeah so you're over it i'm over
it but i'd still play but i'm just not
as excited but i'm still going to play i
i keep seeing i never see you one
because you keep hiding your name on
online so i don't even know when you're
just like playing by myself yeah see you
[ __ ] loner ass that's what i'm
talking about
i mean that's just i've always been like
that yeah but you're not playing alone
that's the [ __ ] up part you're playing
with strangers
what are you talking about well i don't
have to talk to him i just sometimes i
don't want to talk okay that's really
what it is
we're playing yeah i just want to
explore and play that's it don't make me
feel bad for my gaming style what i love
is like on my screen you can't see this
but like right there guys that's the
stevie we reset right there
oh don't go making fun of my apartment
now i'm not we could but we can see all
of it in the reflection in the mirror
oh you can't
yeah it's all right there yeah
so yeah
you haven't watched any movies like
what's your name
i like the fact that you keep going back
to that yeah because i want to know
because people keep asking about movies
and i i'm just surprised
that's what i'm saying i'm surprised
that you talk about 1917 that's the last
new show that's all i'm saying i'm just
shocked that you haven't like
delved into movies you know usually
you'd be like what's your top five
quarantine movies
what's your top five quarantine movies
instead i'm watching black mirror i just
you know i'm watching the old black
mirrors
um and i'm playing destiny or i'm
working on content
that's good how's that going how is the
how's the content going you know what
the show must go on i'm still doing
right now man me too that's why
how long have i been asking you about
doing this it's like three weeks now
since the beginning since i found out we
were quarantined i would hit you up
something steve we should do this we
should do that and this is
three and a half weeks later now you're
on the call
well i'm on oh god
oh no let's not start fighting now
i got on eventually yeah i already told
you i was like
busy trying to wrap my head around all
these other things yeah i know it's a
lot yeah and this is a lot um
can i tell you something about like
what's disheartening and this is like
tell me about it go okay so
so you know with audio boom i had
sponsors right yeah and it was going
good i had purple mattress i had you
know blue chew i had all these but guess
what
so right before this quarantine hit
i don't know it's ironic at timing but i
get an email from one of the execs or
one of the representatives there at
audioboo
and they said uh mr lee unfortunately
we uh the sponsors and advertisers
aren't interested
on
in your pla um in your platform anymore
and what we have a new criteria where
in order for advertisers to to link up
with you you need it get this
and average every on a consistent on a
consistent basis 30 to 50 000 views on
every guest
jesus
so i'm like how am i going to compete
with that you know what i'm saying
that's a lot dude
wow
because you know how it is sometimes if
you have gang cook that's 800 000 yeah
if you have joe blow yeah that's two
thousand yeah yeah yeah yeah it's a lie
and so like now and then on top of that
i'm getting and this is weird
especially the last month i've been
getting hit up by a
scammers trying to get my bank
information trying to take money like
crazy [ __ ]
oh really
yeah they're posing as like a
representative from squarespace
or
stripe or bank of america oh mr lee your
account is closed here click on this to
update your account you know what i'm
saying oh god yeah you know the one i've
been getting this happens i don't know
what the [ __ ] this is man but i keep
getting these facebook messages
they asking for your information no and
they go
we want to advertise on your facebook
page and we pay this amount of money and
it's like
like every day five six messages from
different people saying the same thing
and it's so often and and and their
profiles look so weird i go this got to
be a scam dude i even had because you
know how loud okay since because you
know this you you're looking for your
own sponsors outside of whatever
so i got a spot it's like it was this i
got a sponsor as a sporting goods
company they they agreed to three
mid-rolls um 250 of pop work that they
know me
they know me
they're probably thinking oh we got this
guy this guy's a weirdo we got him
but
they don't understand what it has to do
with that like my my debit card or my
bank or my
my money you know who
no no no no no
yeah so i've been dude they're like
trying every angle on me
like they hit up squarespace and they're
like
that's how i know they know me because
they know my uh websites through
squarespace but then guess what the
transactions are all through stripe
so then they made a fake stripe email
saying your stripe accounting is not up
to date and your bank is closed you need
to update click here yeah this keeps
just keeps the the flowing man
yeah i know i know but hey so now we're
i don't know it's gonna be a zoom
wedding i guess right
we're going
yeah man we're going you know that yeah
of course of course yeah yeah but it's
like i don't know when that's gonna be
because it's like imagine all those
people do that like had birthday parties
and and like all the people that are
supposed to graduate this year and
people that had weddings planned for
right now all those april weddings and
all that kind of stuff it's like damn oh
that's that's that's done you know
that's done so it's like like this
this has nothing to do with people it
doesn't change the fact that it's people
are paranoid as hell right now well i
i don't see how they would be paranoid
about talking on the phone
i'm i'm not them but i'm trying to put
myself in
[Music]
[Laughter]
you
know
please don't do that again you don't
know about these golden rules
all right
yeah
that was that stevie weeby interview uh
[Music]
wanna thank everybody
[Music]
ryan sent judah
[Music]
oh here we go here we go are we back
back in this track
wow eric griffin
this beat go hard
[Music]
all right guys
and we're back in the business uh thanks
for i hope you guys enjoyed that i know
you guys don't understand i pre-record
these things because i don't want people
not everybody wants to go live on a call
they might say something or something
might happen so i pre-recorded i make
sure they're okay with it and then i
play it when i'm doing these live
episodes like this so that's how it's
going to be and some people can't
[ __ ] figure it out they can't wrap
their stupid brain around it
a lot of idiots in the chat but anyway q
a time right now so i'm here
you know i'm here to uh oh god here we
go
okay okay here we
here we go oh we gotta we gotta rap
about it because we got some got some
super chats super chats slippery y'all
slipping out too sent five dollars
thought you knew
st swaggy did it he did it too
did it with 299
to hear me
okay so we back and
yeah so let's get some questions in here
and then we'll uh you know we'll we'll
call it a day we did it you know what i
mean we had some fun we're already at an
hour
um
this is a hundred percent live right now
mark duffy in the chat who's asking me
that was just like i said let me explain
it again
um
we do pre-recorded i do pre-record the
calls that i make with people because
people don't necessarily want to go live
i want to make sure that you know
nothing slips out that they don't want i
want to make sure it's all fixed up
right and then i put it out during my
live episodes like this uh the steve
episode got wonky at the end and i had
to do some work just to salvage it the
way it was right there because it was so
hard to get him on the phone anyway but
so my apologies for the the um
the nonsense
um i don't have an old
boo this is still my boo we've been
together like three years we had a
little break up in the middle but now
we're still together so
we actually met on instagram
if you can believe that
like she
she was a fan of i'm dying up here not
even workaholics i'm dying up here and
like she sent me a friend request but
then she liked like three of my pictures
and when you're that's a hot chick sleep
that's how high checks going to the dm
they don't really go into the dm they
just they just put it out there like
only like three of these pictures then i
saw her and i looked at her little
picture and i was like oh [ __ ] what's up
and then i slid into the dms
so here and then here we are three like
almost four years
later i'm not going to talk about
brendan schaub special
so please stop asking me about that in
the chat y'all so stupid
and mean
uh
[Music]
[Music]
this ain't pre-recorded
[ __ ]
we in this chat live silly sucker
here on eric griffin
we live and we riffing and slipping
got a big nose so
[Music]
hear it from your head to your feet
by the way if you want if you're a
producer and you want these are all like
fan beats
people send me these little beats
they're so dope um
and there's really talented people out
there so if you
have some music that you want to send
just email me eric airgriffin.com if you
go to my about thing you can see all the
ways that you could uh hit me up
steve and i were talking about that show
maria conda
tidying up with maria
that show is so it's it's really
interesting
if you want to straighten up your place
if you have like just just how you fold
shirts and all that kind of stuff the
things you learned on that show was
pretty cool and it was pretty dope that
when i talked to steve i didn't realize
that he knew all about her he wasn't
even watching the netflix show he was
reading her book
so it's like a really she's kind of like
a like a spiritual like she makes it all
a spiritual experience you know like
there's a whole there's a meditation
portion and there's like thanking your
things and but when you get done like
how would you ever like watch something
have been like damn i want my place to
look neat and and not as cluttered or
whatever i mean there's there's things
you have to do you have to like get rid
of things you have to put things away
you have to like all the extra stuff you
have that you don't need you got to get
rid of so i'm in the process of doing
that right now
the beard of knowledge i like that
[Laughter]
i know i feel like gandalf right now but
i don't know i talked about it in the
beginning of the episode i think i'm uh
i think i'm gonna keep this what do
y'all think you know think i should keep
it
i'm gonna keep it anyway because what
can i do about it now it is what it is
it is what it is you know what i mean uh
oh uh oh
yeah
oh it's only
it's two dollars
but it's two euros
my heroes
here we go
here we go with the flow
jack hill from i don't know where where
he from
from glasgow
i love you son
thanks for that two-year-old
i can be your hero
be all in the chat
keeping the fact
jaden
not sure where you're from
but your name is kind of funny
[ __ ] son
oh you talk about we should all meditate
that's great keep it great
and recovery great
oh let's meditate in these quarantine
times
we're gonna try to take these quarantine
times
right on time
okay i do suggest meditating though guys
you know we were talking earlier if you
if you're just getting here you know you
can start the episode over but if you're
just getting here i was talking earlier
about like everybody has certain
feelings you know like we all are having
like moments of depression moments of
like hating our current life and that's
fine but take some time to
you know take some time to like
breathe you know i've been doing some
meditating where they had this thing
where we'll do it after we wait we got
one more super chat then we'll do well
i'll show you guys what to do
oh [ __ ]
oh we got two here we go we got three
oh mr brian alexander
with that dollar ninety-nine
that dollar ninety-nine ryan two dollars
about to kick some prize
jeff give me all his money that [ __ ] say
funny
here we go
with that sick ass flow yeah
that's how we do talking about maria
gonna do
in the chat kicking these rods as a
matter of fact
[Music]
so stupid
[Laughter]
anyways
all right let me tell you guys something
sometimes you have overwhelming feelings
of anxiety and depression and and you
just feel like you don't know how to get
out of that
some meditation breaths are real dope
okay
let's actually do some meditation
breaths right now and it's just simply
like in through your nose out through
your mouth so i like to do in four
meaning four seconds you count four
seconds like one two three four so
and then out for six
try that [ __ ] y'all i'm telling you it's
helpful and another thing too
uh i'll see you johnny oh just a second
another thing too is when you close your
eyes
and then
make yourself look in the center
for some reason that motion
relaxes your face
you know so when you close your eyes and
you pretend as if not pretend but
actually do it in your mind's eye look
in the center of yourself right here
and then when you do that
it makes everything sort of relaxed and
make yourself relax guys make yourself
relax you know just
make yourself a good place to do is
actually on the toilet i'll explain
after this
[Music]
oh johnny o you need a new beat
oh [ __ ]
oh
so you know
if y'all don't know oh [ __ ] we got ten
dollars mo
[Music]
who what's it
[Music]
who was it oh
mark duffy's back again sending twenty
dollars he's a good ass friend
making all y'all ashamed
i'm in the hall of fame
mark stuffy liking this beer
20
he got no fear
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
do the whole [ __ ] right
[Music]
okay anyway
so anyways i know if y'all out there can
we get some okay let's just get a little
a couple of questions if y'all want some
questions
um
i wish i wish mark duffy was a bobby lee
burner account that i can call him and
be like thanks brother
uh if you got some questions for me so i
answered the question about the
girlfriend situation um if anybody else
has the other question this chat's a
little late so
so i gotta kind of like wait but i'll
just keep talking in the meantime
you know um it's been
like i don't know how it is
somebody said i'm a mix between drake
and dj khaled
[Laughter]
i wish
[ __ ] i wish i had i wish i had that i
wish i had just like 20 of that drake dj
khaled money again though if you want to
send me some beats if you a producer out
there you want your beat on on my
podcast
or
i put them on my gaming show all the
time
yeah so
on the on the gaming show they're on all
the time
if you want to see some gaming i play i
play black ops i play uh warzone all the
time i play with fans so if you want to
play it's cross platform so don't matter
if you have a playstation xbox or
if you have a pc you know you can see me
right there on my eric griffin gaming
channel it's twitch.tv era griffin
gaming and also on youtube so i go live
on sometimes i go live on youtube but
most of the time i'll go live on twitch
and then i'll put those recordings on my
youtube to see the replays especially if
there's good stuff like i won yesterday
you know i had a good group of people
and we won so that stuff's fun to do so
you know
um
mix between joey diaz and brodie stevens
okay enough with what i'm mixed with
okay pieces of [ __ ]
[Laughter]
uh but i will be playing warzone in a
little while but like i said guys um i
really appreciate you guys watching and
and all that stuff it's like you know
this is
this has been really hard but i'm still
trying to like put out content i'm still
trying to like you know keep [ __ ]
flowing and growing and i really do
appreciate every time you guys every
time you guys uh uh
listen
every time you guys interact with me and
all that stuff i really do appreciate it
you know so we're gonna wrap it up now
guys because it's already been an hour
and i don't want to go too much longer
than that so
as always i want to thank you guys for
watching and listening please subscribe
please share please uh send all your uh
good stuff for your favorite podcasts
[Music]
anyway guys i believe thank you guys for
watching and we i will see you next week
i most likely will be live again next
week uh friday i'm gonna go live i have
a donnell rollins uh call that i
recorded so once again if you come back
next week there's gonna be a portion of
it that's recorded but most of it's
gonna be live and i'll be singing and
rapping and having some fun with y'all
and you guys have been great and i
appreciate everybody that sent super
chats you guys are awesome
jeff three buttholes mark woozit and all
you guys that are supporting the show
and thanks for watching you know what i
mean thanks for watching uh who else
dylan
another person named ryan louise shawn
justin cody liz riley
um ray
all right so thanks for watching ripping
with griffin
you guys will be great take care
[Music]